كل عام وانتم بخير اما احنا مش بخير طبعا
مش بخير ايش بدك من شعب نها حياته 2023
بحرب وبدا 2024 بحرب انتم كلكم بتحتفل
واحنا بنموت يعني اللي ما استشهدت امه
اللي ما استشهد ابوه اخوه اللي ما استشهد
حد من ئته راحت داره يا انحرقت يا انهدت
صح ولا لا اولا ثانيا على مدار اكثر من 85
يوم بنعاني في حياتنا بنعاني في الاكل
والشرب بنعاني في حياتنا اصلا يوميه ح
يعني احنا فيش نت فيش اكل فيش افتكر
حياتنا نت مش على النت احنا مش قادرين
نعيش احنا تعبنا في حياتنا هجروا الشعب
قتلوه عدمو عدموا عنه كل شيء يعني احنا مش
عارفين عن الناس اللي بره ايش يعني اهلنا
كلهم في الجنوب مش عارفين عنهم شيء اللي
في الجنوب مش عارفين عنا شيء قطعوا
التواصل عنا بالمره عن اي سلام بتحكوا عن
اي حياه بتحكوا عن اي احتفالات بتحكوا كل
الدنيا مبسوطه بكره وكل الحياه مبسوطه
والعيشه والدنيا ودين اما احنا مش مبسوطين
ولا عايشين احنا كل يوم كل يوم بنموت وكل
يوم بيجي اصعب من اخوه يعني بروح امبارح
اليوم اصعب من امبارح بكره بيجي اصعب
وبعده اصعب كل يوم بنموت وكل يوم بنعاني
وماحدش مدور علينا فدمتم بخير وخلص اجدي
احكيكم يعني
بس y